[Laughter]
greetings from podcastville
the church of what's happened now is
brought to you by
stamps.com listen as we slowly adjust
into a new normal
we still need to do business as usual
how are you supposed to do that
while keeping six feet away from other
people how
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things a lot easier
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits
of using stamps.com in recent months
they've been able to keep their business
going while avoiding crowds at the post
office
listen you print the postage at home and
you skip the lines
with stamps.com plus you save money on
discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office and now
stamps.com is working with ups so you
get discounts up to 62 percent
how's that for you listen my wife sends
out t-shirts
and mugs and a bunch of [ __ ] and
stamps.com
is the way to go you leave it out the
mailman picks it up
next thing you know you got a mug coming
to your [ __ ] house [ __ ] so
right now
they got a special offer for the church
family
stamps.com will give you a four-week
trial plus
free postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
it's very easy
you go to stamps.com click the
microphone on the top of the home page
and press in church c-h-u-r-c-h
grab the pen c-h-u-r-c-h that's it
that's it
at sams.com press church and stay
safe it's wednesday the 26th of august
kick this [ __ ] mule lee oh
[ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today all
right no more [ __ ] excuse me
we're going in like [ __ ] marines
[Music]
wednesday we're down to two more
[ __ ] podcasts we got felicia
michaels
in studio they're very beautiful felicia
michaels well thank you mr diaz what's
happening
oh you know just doing my thing my
pandemic thing
it's been rough huh it's been crazy yeah
cause my kids have been there i have a
19 as you know and a 21 year old
and so yeah that's been i
can i i know i know i know
trust me i know oh my god and at the
beginning of it
it was rough making them understand what
the [ __ ] is going on
and i kicked my son in the balls
oh i did why what'd he
i do told you ten years ago i was
telling you that one day
you were gonna have a when you have a
boy when you have a son
and the dad's not around usually they
get to an age one day because we do it
to our dads
why don't we do it to our moms right
we're stepping to our dads one day
we actually think we can beat our dads
out until they just punch you in the
neck
[Laughter]
so if boys do that to men their fathers
one day they kind of get snippy with
their moms
oh yeah and you have no time there's not
yeah
if you play that white psychology [ __ ]
yeah they're gonna kill you
yeah for sure for sure
yeah you know what it was [ __ ]
freeing oh
you know what i mean like you took
somebody in the nuts oh yeah
that's been bothering you during the
pandemic yeah that's tremendous that's
that's something you could pay a shrink
ten times you don't get the satisfaction
yeah
or just kicking somebody really hard in
the nuts it's driving you crazy they're
a pandemic
because and that's what the thing has
been like i've really been worried i
i've enjoyed doing the podcast because
i know that there's a lot of people
right now that
never had mental health issues but this
this type of living this type of uh news
gathering the way it's being thrown at
you
oh yeah it'll bring it'll bring [ __ ]
uh
you know the mind of whatever down i
don't care who the [ __ ] you are
and that's why i like to take an hour
just to come here
[ __ ] loosen people up a little bit
you know
when i get anxiety now it's when i
answer messages for people
yeah my anxiety goes away at night i get
that nine o'clock anxiety i get on the
computer
right and you get on patreon facebook
and you just start answering people's
messages
that's it 100 because at the beginning
of the pandemic
like i went with them for such a long
period of time where we weren't around
anyone and it got like you know like
every like once a month four weeks in
it's a big kabuy because you're just
sitting there
uh you know with busy little hands
and nothing to do you know you know when
the exercise is a big part of it yes
today i woke up on the wrong side of the
bed i went to the gym
and while i was at the gym it came back
to me like i was fresh again
i took like a falling off the bike gave
me a little bit of a beating yesterday
it was just a rough
yeah a rough day how did it happen
i woke up in the middle of the night you
know we had those tanks we were loading
for the pods and we had one loaded and
you know
uh they're talking about stealing people
robbing a lot of [ __ ]
so i woke up before and i [ __ ]
went for the piece and i ran outside
like a lunatic
because i just thought i heard something
i didn't hear [ __ ]
that i couldn't fall asleep again you
know you see a lot of weird [ __ ] at
night
i take a ride every night last night was
the weirdest
last night i [ __ ] took a ride at
about 9 30 at night and right down the
corner there was a cat in the middle of
the street
and i'm like this somebody hit this
[ __ ]
he was alive as disco he just wanted to
play in the middle
i had to get of the the car and walk up
to him yeah he's sick
the cat is okay i can tell he's sick
he's on his last legs
he was kind of disoriented so i pushed
him to the sidewalk like
i would get close to him he'd move up
and thank god i went in the car i knew i
had a can of something whether it was
cat food
and i had a little can of cat food and i
opened it for it then i went home last
night and i kind of felt guilty
so i got back in the car like after i
spoke to you one of those times when i
try to call you back
right that's right that i came back to
check on him the can was still there but
he was gone
he ate a little bit but i saw some [ __ ]
i saw a lot of people in suvs like one
of
those
escalades a lot of escalades playing
loud music
like base heavy bass i saw like three or
four
in this neighborhood and that's not good
to set this type of neighborhood this
neighborhood is really changing
it's one i think everything has changed
like i went to hollywood yesterday and i
at like uh eight o'clock at night i was
uh
driving off through east hollywood and
uh there are people's houses on the curb
you know what i mean and it's been uh
slowly getting worse
but it looks like you know it's people
are getting evicted people are choosing
to leave
people are cutting bait and running
that [ __ ] sycamore tavern when you
see
the grass coming out of the street like
the
concrete like the driveway like grass is
starting to grow on that driveway i go
back to when that place is acapulco
i used that right remember yeah it was
acapulco
all you could eat for lunch tremendous
enchiladas like a
[ __ ] they had one there and then
they also had one acapulco was by the
sycamore
and then they also had one if you stayed
on sunset
you pass the scientology and you make a
right like you're going to silver lake
right there where pinchas tacos is that
taco place where white people go
you know what you're talking about oh my
god they put pickles in their tacos and
[ __ ]
yeah that place it's next to that
acapulco and that used to be empty
so fat dudes would go up there and tear
it up me ralphy
key tree ball we were in acapulco every
[ __ ] day
and was it good though yes oh nice it
was good enough
yeah i was going to say it come on it
was a lot
the state place there was the state
place on lebron
for [ __ ] you mean sizzler yes
okay oh my god i i used to eat there
all day every time you got like a 40
dollar check that yeah that was like a
celebration
speaking of that because i know we all
live in in the valley or you
used to have you been up my street
up to like where the gold gym used to be
in the sizzler yeah
gold gym is gone sizzler's gone they're
living in like the little did they call
they closed gold's gym i think so it
doesn't look like the signs gone
yeah well they were they built a mall up
there
yeah a nice one a nice one but it's
become
[ __ ] not a living dead up there so i
don't know what's going to happen
entire blocks i had to go over there
that's where my dentist is oh [ __ ] okay
we're all the way past that bat under
the bridge yeah it's scary
then i drive back i saw that strip club
that looks like lonely [ __ ]
because they're stripping but they're
stripping outside did you know that what
did you know that the strip clubs are
open
on uh a blanket no no not those
disgusting ones you know like well the
strip club is a strip club
right they're open the health department
has let them open in certain cities
right but you gotta dance outside
yeah so here you are in your car driving
down the side street
and he's [ __ ] some chick doing a
table dancing
a lot of fly traps out in the parking
lot but
george is working one george perez works
the lunchtime shift
as a dj during the day outside oh my god
they got 88 customs yesterday it goes
down a lot he goes
[ __ ] yeah he goes people are burning
through those unemployment checks
at the strip club holy [ __ ] i can see
lee's friends are back he's got two
we gotta bring him we gotta run i gotta
invite my friends
wow so stripping is like [ __ ] big
right now
i'm big on like actually keeping things
closed
but if strip clubs are open comedy
should be open that's crazy that's crazy
i still wouldn't go to the strip club
right but i'm just saying that strip
clubs
are getting creative they are outside
now there's a chicken
for those girls but [ __ ] man that's
terrible
that's terrible the pool will get real
hot in this money you know those girls
have uh big lives a lot of math kids a
lot of them
you know are going to school a lot of
them you know
so i'm not mad at him it's funny i
watched that jennifer lopez movie about
stripping
uh-huh it was on one of the paychecks
one night
and i watched on a plane first it was on
a plane
i was on a plane one time and it was on
like let me see what it was about
the chinese girl is really cute so i
kind of kept my attention
but it was have you seen that movie no
called sponsors right hustlers yeah it's
about strippers that
[ __ ] just take you down oh okay yeah
they just take you [ __ ] down like the
whole thing wasn't it based on a real
person
yeah yeah oh yeah and you know it's so
funny like
you they'll rob you don't [ __ ] you
know a good stripper that's what their
job is to [ __ ] rob you
to promise you you're gonna he's gonna
they're gonna
suck your dick till the juice comes out
but they don't do nothing
that's the best stripper the one that
tells you you're gonna eat your [ __ ]
and meanwhile you're giving the 20s and
she'll
she's going to meet you denny's at two
that's the one
that's the best strippers at the bar
spouting [ __ ] so she doesn't have to
do that much dance yeah
it's great stripper but they would take
them like credit cards [ __ ] they were
like
they were killing stock market guys
killing them well cardi b
came out because she's in that movie and
she came out and told
people got really mad at her because she
was basically drugging people
and
if you're a man and you're gonna let
yourself that happen to you
what are you gonna do i guess
you gotta read if a girl comes up to you
when it's that easy
right you gotta know there's a by the
way coming somewhere there's a locked
door somewhere
nobody just comes up to you and starts
talking to you
and makes it that easy for you unless
there's a by the way somewhere
right i agree you know right when you
get them in the cars
with the by the way you have to be
pretty sloppy at a strip club for a girl
to
you know rob you yeah and do that that's
being pretty sloppy
wow have you ever had anything like that
happen
i've been to i've i've been three times
twice with george and it was fun with
george because george is the king of
that strip club and
and they all love him so they're nice to
me but that's like that's part of the
reason why i never went
it just it just felt like it felt weird
like i was like this isn't
real i'm just paying to get a boner
like i don't know it never really made
sense to me
just getting paid to get frustrated i
don't know what the point
it was great they're fun and they're
beautiful and right it's fun
if i if i was rich if i like didn't care
about 500 bucks i could see myself going
once a month but i'm still at a point
where it's like
why am i spending 300 bucks here right
it's uh
i'm not i'm not at that point yet but
it's fun i i can see it being
the one the one thing i still don't
understand is like going with a bunch of
guy friends
and hanging out with them like when
george was there
we i'd see him and i'd see his but his
buddies but we'd split up
and like like the real perverts that you
are yeah i can't i can't i don't
understand going to vegas like i've been
in vegas 10 times
i've never once been i can't imagine
being at a table with all my other guy
buddies having
all of us having boners just sitting
there uncomfortable just
that part doesn't sound like fun to me
yeah take your corners
it's it's crazy i'm like i think i start
i start on a strip club guy you know i
started out a
a peep show guy like my first sex like
an old school
people yeah when you're 14 13 in new
york city
you go to the peep shows you know and
you see people [ __ ] in front of you
wait do you mean movies or do you mean
like actually like actually oh good lord
and it's you know looking back at it you
laugh
right but it is the most disgusting
experience that you could ever do as a
man like
to walk into a closet watch two people
[ __ ]
pull your dick out jerk off you open the
door and there's a little [ __ ]
spanish guy with a mop
and a bucket i think he goes in
he wipes up your jizz and he puts it in
a bucket
fill the little abortions
[Laughter]
because that's and it was just horrible
like when you're 13 you play hooky
you go at 10 in the morning right and
you walk out and you're like wow
what the [ __ ] did we just see you know
this
and then you're happy because at 13 you
saw a [ __ ]
and pits yeah but when you when you
realize it you're just looking at a
train wreck
she's just a train wreck like they were
just and i didn't realize until
i was older like when i was in my 30s i
would get off
the bus right there in port authority
and in those days for breakfast
breakfast was what it was
you know and for me it was that hot dog
stand right by times square right by a
[ __ ]
uh border doherty on the corner not
grace papaya
no no it was a hot dog stand that had
kebabs
two dollar kebabs i get two [ __ ]
kebabs for breakfast
but i watched peep world the name of it
was peep world do you remember
the laugh factory opened up a club right
right behind it
oh okay it was called peep world and i
would sit there and lead and eat the
[ __ ] kabobs at 8 15 in the morning
i wouldn't have to be at work till 9 9
15. they wouldn't say nothing to me
and i'd want and you know it was the
majority of the people going in there
acidic jews the seeds would go in there
and not make eye contact with you
and then i would go let me go just go
one day i said let me go just go see
what's going on there
and it's like going to the circus you
walk in there's a guy whatever oh no
absolutely
it's very social oh yeah it's a guy with
tokens
and you give him five hours and he gives
you [ __ ] tokens
and then you walk into the back you
could smell like chlorine
yeah oh it's like sperm chlorine yeah
exactly chlorine chlorine
yeah and you see men walking around but
nobody's really making eye contact
because you're not supposed to be there
okay what are they walking around for
because they're looking to see their
corner there's different corners
there's different chicks like felicia
made the movie
yeah pervs which joey was in and you can
get it on amazon
but uh but it was done in the peep show
the last working peep show in los
angeles and that smell is dirty mop
water bleach and sperm which and
and sperm kind of to me has like a a
bloody mary kind of smell
to it right i [ __ ] just nailed it in
california that smells like sperm
i don't know every once in a while
you'll be i'll be walking out this
smells warm outside
x movie there was one on sunday nights
in jersey
and one night my buddy's like yeah let's
go to this triple x we were just
seniors in high school like six of us
went
and when you go in the bathroom that's
when the party would start
like two guys would follow you in and
they would be
so perverted that they would walk over
to you and try to look at your dick
while you were pissing
then when you call them they look away i
would like to uh
just say like uh you know i was stripper
we all know that when i was 18.
and but i remember
like i really need the [ __ ] money and
it was like this contest
and i didn't give a [ __ ] and no one had
ever taught no man had ever had a
conversation with me other than
you know trying to get some right and i
remember being on
stage and i was dancing and there was a
guy i looked down he's like jerking off
and let me tell you it was [ __ ]
powerful it was powerful
it was like yeah [ __ ] these people
powerful
if you're when you get to that point
where you have to do something like that
where you know what i mean it's
it's [ __ ] i've jerked off outside
[ __ ] it's not a sad moment
it's not a sad moment i'm coming down
off coke i'm jerked off in the car when
i lived in my car
i'm not gonna lie to you about that but
to take your dick out and just wipe off
at a girl
i've never done that that's the craziest
[ __ ] day in the world
that's the craziest most just to take
your dick out like to louis ck somebody
kills me like i don't get that whole
thing till this day
but that was his twist that was the
twist that made him brilliant
you follow me there's people certain
people like certain
deep dark [ __ ] you know yeah that was
the twist
because if nobody ever accused him of
rape and nothing like that nobody said
he was a bad guy
his thing was to whack off while he was
talking to you on the phone
or to ask you if he could whack off in
front of you how do you find out that
i guess just it just right as you're
asking the first girl can i whack off in
front of you
that's my thing listen you see things as
a child
they make you react differently and you
know something could have happened
there's more to this story that we'll
never
know and he said how long do you know
him he's a sweetheart of a guy
he gave me two jobs i can never talk bad
about louie
i'm just talking i'm not i'm not talking
bad about louie
i'm talking about the psychology of what
i knew a girl
i knew a girl i had a dear friend that
when you saw her you couldn't believe it
like you were like okay this girl's
pretty nice
she always was in the hunt for a
boyfriend but
i heard years later when she'd go on the
road she would have threesomes
and then let you know guys would run
trains rather headliner in the feature
you know
i heard that years later that was her
thing
when you look at it why would she do
that
that was her thing if i was a female
comic i wouldn't sleep with comics
but i would go on the road and work like
a male comic
and get myself a piece of [ __ ] work
them dry
and then throw them out in the morning
like a [ __ ]
because a man can't throw a woman out in
the morning but a woman could throw a
man out in the morning
you never threw me out no i got my boss
to tell somebody to leave
have you seen my dick no thankfully if
you've seen anything
if you suck my dick you're doing me a
great faith i don't have the balls
you've just left though oh yeah you
leave because
it's time to go okay
but you can't as a woman i've had
honestly honestly i've had like when i
was younger
i had like three women that dismissed me
it's a horrible feeling how was what was
it like to be dismissed like what was
the move did they have similar moves
when they dismissed you
one chick i was in love with not really
in love with
i was in love with a [ __ ] i was 20
i was 20 and she was 29. big difference
right oh [ __ ] she dismissed you oh my
god it was horrible
she used a sponge back then oh okay
the worst she we were friends we were
neighbors
and i never ever intruded on her never
spoke sexually to her i was a 20 year
old kid
i didn't know how to treat her i just
thought she was hot she had that
what's the mom from married with
children
katie she had that katie type thing when
katie seagal was younger
like when i first saw katie seagal i was
like
oh my god it looks like i don't even
remember what the girl's name now
she had a sister and i kind of had a
crush on the sister
because i saw the sister one day
watching tv
and she had shorts on and i could tell
her [ __ ] was hairy as [ __ ] it was
i could see the hair she had she left
the leg open so you could see the bush
come out
and i was like this sister's [ __ ] hot
and the sister was about 25.
but the one that was 29 was also hot so
she cut hair
and she worked at a wine store at night
she cut hair in the daytime
and then from the barber shop she went
to a wine store where she was a general
manager
she was like a whiny chick like she knew
all about wines and stuff
it was my first girlfriend in colorado
we moved next to each other
we lived next to each other april may
and june and one day in june she's
cutting my hair
right and we're talking about something
and she goes you know it's been crazy to
me
that you and none of your friends have
ever hit on any of us
and i go you know what we're all from
the same town and we're all raised the
same
you're our neighbors we don't see the we
don't want to bring
drama to the house and she goes it would
it would have felt a little better
before you left or something to that
effect that one
is would at least hit on us at one time
because it was a great place to live it
was called
uh maroon it was oh my god it was in
basalt colorado
you know 83 and it was like uh
a side it was condos and they were all
built going up the hill
right but nobody locked their doors
everybody had a screen door your dog was
outside
you know it was a mile from the road so
you had to make a right onto the
property
drive a mile and then all these houses
were there next to each other and
everybody's house was open
the guy that lived next to me was an
ex-green bay
uh cleveland brown big [ __ ] he
used to drink every day
come over bring his drinks hey i'm a
brand new
young eyed criminal but taking a little
breather
at the time i had no money put away i
was taking a little breather
i didn't want to rob any of those
apartments because they were impacted on
me my buddies would have begun on me
so i didn't do anything i behaved myself
like a gentleman so one day these girls
cut
my hair and she's just like poking me
like
what surprise you guys gay like manny
hasn't ever tried nothing and i go so
what do you want me to tell you
and she goes uh what do you think of me
and i go honestly i think you're [ __ ]
harder now
i think you got a great [ __ ] ass and
you know i told the truth you want me to
tell you
and she told me she goes when do you
move out
and i go july 21st and she goes we have
a date july 2nd
she goes i gotta rule out [ __ ] my
neighbors either
i said okay so i moved in
with my roommate that was living next to
me uh-huh
that would you know it was four guys
from north bergen my roommate's name was
jimmy berkel
god rest his son he died years later i
still miss him i haven't taken his
number out of my phone
he was my brother and we lived together
i never really told him
that i dated that i was gonna date this
girl
so seriously i moved july 1st
and july 2nd she came up
he went away with his girlfriend and
left me in the house
i had just moved there so july 1st was
like a friday night
and they took me out to aspen we went
out to aspen because it was right next
door but
we took the bus and i blacked out i got
[ __ ] ham and i did blow
and i remember i didn't know what
apartment building to go to and i
knocked on the guy's door
and he opened and i'm like do i live
here and he's like nah
[Laughter]
i know he's 12. i live in apartment 12
this apartment 12 he goes maybe you're
up
and he ended walking me up to d12 where
i lived right
guy's name was bergy he was from
pittsburgh
i ended up becoming friends with him do
i live here
do i live here he's like nah but he was
a nice guy
right he walked me i went home that was
like the weirdest weekend of my life
that tuesday that saturday morning
i had to go into town to aspen
to buy like cds or something i wasn't
buying like a new cd
there was a cd store that was next to
the wine store
that that girl worked okay so i went
into the wine store and i go what's
going on where's our date
and she goes i get out of here about
five i was gonna come up to your
apartment in snowmass village i'm like
oh like this is real
like i didn't think so you're 29 i'm 20.
right like this is real like i'm like
what what happened to her like i was
joking
why do i date and she was i was just
kidding i was just about to call you
i'm gonna come over and after i get out
so i [ __ ] ran down to the thing
i was waiting there to take a bus and
there was a hitchhiker there was a
hitching post
there's a hitching post so i hitchhiked
and the guy told me he goes i can't give
you a ride
up to snowmass village i could only give
you a ride to the bottom of the village
then cross 82 and hitchhike up to
snowmass village i go fine
i don't know who the guy was but that's
how life was
that you would get into a person's car
they had a bench in aspen with a sign
that had this on it and it was a and
this meant
i'm only going a little way people were
that nice that they beat they even go
lee
i'm only going this far or some people
go come on get in where you going
glenwood springs glenwood springs was
the farthest
you had basalt you had snowmass village
some people went up the hill to go to
the village
some people would drop you off at the
bottom you got to walk across now
look it up route 82 one of the most
dangerous [ __ ]
roads in the country oh yeah once
november
oh oh yeah that's why you don't go out
when you're living out you stay in
snowmass because
people get killed all the time on 82. so
but in the summer it's a little
different
in the summer it's a little different so
i uh
cross the street i go across the street
i'm standing there with my thumb out
and you don't even have to stand with
your mouth people pull over and one of
those jeeps pulls up
with the eagle in front of it on the
hood
yeah yeah yeah it was convertible but he
had the top on
i walked to the car because he went by
me and he stopped
so i had to run up to the car i was a
little you know it's my
it's 12 000 feet you know it's a little
higher than basalt
and i was kind of huffing and puffing i
was in great shape yeah i remember
walking and i didn't even look at the
guy i said thank you when i looked
it was john [ __ ] denver jack
you shut the [ __ ] up i guess it was
serious yes it was oh my god you're not
john denver he goes yes i am how are you
doing
because i'm going to do my annual fourth
of july thing
snowmass village he goes come on i'll
give you a ride and he gave me a ride to
the supermarket i shook his hand we
talked
and then i ran home i went to the
supermarket bought some [ __ ]
i went home we basically had a tv with a
milk crate on top of it
we had like a homemade couch with
another
milk crate with uh a board a piece of
wood
and then we had the two bedrooms my
bedroom was just a sheet
and a pillow do you call it a homemade
couch
was your milk carton jimmy berkel made
put this [ __ ] thing together
of something pillows and there was one
channel it was aspen channel 2.
and the only movie they played was
[ __ ] a charles bronson movie
because they knew when charles bronson
was up there so they would replay his
movies over and over
because charles liked his movies on tv
you think i'm [ __ ] lying to you
there was one channel lee aspen two
until we got cable
how many times did you watch that
charles mr majestic was the movie that
was on all
[ __ ] weekend and then she came over
she called and said she was what was the
address i told the d12
she came right in and she goes let's you
know again guys i'm from new york city
you know
i don't know nothing she was a white
chick and she's like what are we doing
inside you know
we should don't you have a lawn and i'm
like yeah she goes let's squash
the wall yeah you don't want to [ __ ]
around milk carton furniture
but my lawn was a shed lawn it was like
there were other condos
on the bottom floor so we just went out
there with a sheet
i've never seen that she put like a
blanket out
and she brought wine and brie cheese i
know i
was the american cheese where's the
mozzarella and she's like american
she brought free cheese i nev and apples
i had never
in my life seen that before that is
hilarious i'm like what is this and
she's like you put some of the debris on
the apple
and i'm like oh this [ __ ] chick is
crazy all right
this trick is this chick is crazy i
don't know about this [ __ ] but it was
good
and then we just went inside it was
natural we just
made love we went into the shower you
made love i think you gave it like three
stabbings that day
and it was so [ __ ] good that
she dismissed you no no no no
i gave her a stabbing that saturday
afternoon
and she left saturday afternoon and
slept in the house
and i was at that age where the [ __ ]
was so good that i kept jerking off
because the [ __ ] was so good i kept i
couldn't take it till the next time
and she's like just call me whenever you
want to see me i'm like
guess what i want to see you again
tomorrow so i woke up at that moment i
couldn't take it no more i was jerking
off all morning
i called i'm like i'm coming down and
she goes come down i was gonna cook i
went back down and it was all day
all night i remember one night we stayed
up all night [ __ ] we'd do a little
bit of coke
and she wouldn't shave her [ __ ] she was
older and she was just beautiful
she had an italian look to her so this
went on
this just went on for like
four months where the first month was
heavy duty sex
but after that it was just how corey
when i want to give you a stabbing
and then that went up for about two
months and then it started getting a
little serious like she's like i want
you to meet my friends and i'm like
i don't mean nobody like i don't want to
meet nobody
right and then one day i went down there
to a house or something
and we messed around and she wanted me
to go
to see the rocky horror picture
oh yeah and in those days i remember
that that happened
and she would get dressed up and her
friends who get dressed up and
sing the songs and [ __ ] it was a little
too much for me i was straight out of
jersey right then
i remember selling a listen you got two
options tonight
you could come over to the house and i
can give you a stabbing or i'm going to
go see trading places
okay fair enough it was like october
november of 83.
we messed around for that long and all
of a sudden
she said to me i'm not going to see
trading places
and i go what do you mean she goes i'm
not going to see trading places you have
to come with me
when she says you have to come with me i
looked at i'm like i'm not gone
and she goes well you might as well just
leave
and that was it i never spoke to her
again what
sandy was in there yeah come on sandy
yeah but that wasn't her dismissing you
she dismissed me right there yeah i
thought i thought dismissing meant more
like
you know just threw you to the side oh
no the way you're saying it it's like
you were [ __ ] if you don't meet a
girl
when i first moved here i met a girl one
night took me home
we did everything and the next morning
she looked me straight in the face and
she goes
i hope you're not expecting breakfast
you can leave oh yeah
more of those stories it wasn't like
once the alcohol were all
right and she looked at me in the light
she was like
there's no breakfast here you could go
and i remember leaving there like it was
down by like third avenue
right i think like a cab i didn't know
what i was like on a monday morning like
i've been dismissed yeah dude
do you feel bad as a guy when you get
dismissed yeah how would you feel if
yeah you know especially if you ate her
ass and a [ __ ] you did everything that
was expected of you
okay really i had to happen once and i
was kind of happy
it was like a girl that we we had just
only had we hooked up like two or three
times and it was like the last time
and we finished she's like you know if
you're not gonna sleep over you don't
really have to
cuddle like you could just leave and i
left i was just like 45 minutes
see that's being dismissed i was i was
that's a terrible feeling like yeah for
sure like it's a [ __ ] horrible
feeling you know so you think
the other way how can you say that to
somebody especially after you smell my
balls how can i [ __ ] just dismiss you
yeah i'm saying
to bring it back to normal you know
something but no it's a
it's a horrible feeling you know it's a
[ __ ] terrible feeling
but it happens it happens who gives a
[ __ ] i wonder what sandy's doing now i
still think about i just remember her
name just now
that was like the weirdest i had two
weird relationships like that
i had another one where i met a girl i
sold her a car
she brought her boyfriend on like this
cannot be happening
this good-looking broad cannot be dead
in this [ __ ] mutt
she didn't know how that she was at 12.
right she had no idea she had a body for
days that she was
12. she dressed down she was one of
those [ __ ]
that didn't really show the goods right
but she just had the goods
and i'm gonna sell that car going i'm
gonna [ __ ] this chick like this
no two ways about it look at this
[ __ ] guy for a boy
she should be ashamed of herself her
father never talked to her
i mean the guy was a half of a [ __ ]
man and i called her three days later
just to check up on how's the car
running
what's going on and i would call every
like 10 days how's the car running and
she goes are you asking me for something
let's go on a date she wanted a date
we had a couple drinks she didn't drink
because she was a rehab counselor
oh okay oh so like the first time i met
i had a couple of bumps with me
she had to downplay it i'm like oh
and like two days later she told me she
broke up with the guy because i couldn't
deal with him no more
he was my college boyfriend and then we
just went on
full straight on we even got in the car
and drove to colorado together
got all the way to colorado were you in
colorado huh weren't you in colorado no
i was in jersey i remember you were
selling cars in germany and go with
cliffs new jersey
is that who you came to colorado that's
what i came to colorado
not the first time the second time in 93
yeah we drove out like three days in a
jeep and
she got an apartment i had zero dollars
i had like eleven hundred dollars
so she goes you could stay here until
you get your own apartment
i moved in with my cousin and because
she was a drug counselor
yeah so she would buy the book she
didn't know but i would go over there
get evil like you know eat a monkey and
then do a couple lines on myself in the
bedroom
and get evil and get hard lines and [ __ ]
and she was just
a nice girl one day she told me she goes
i know you're getting high don't come
here anymore
and she opened the door and said get out
and i got out
did you feel as bad that time as the
other time i never felt
you feel bad listen you feel bad
but there comes a point when you're
a young like like but by the age of 24
as a man you've either met your
girlfriend
that you're gonna marry or you're on a
slinging dick cycle
okay okay and what that means is you got
to kiss a lot of frogs
to get to your prince right okay and
it's it's i think it's hard it was one
of the things i regretted
the most about my life like i could tell
you i had great times
but those women that you know
how can we what's the best way to put it
without
hurting anybody's feelings just our
interactions
like today as a man i look at my
daughter and i feel those interactions
like they went nowhere like you know
what i'm saying like we did dirty things
and it went nowhere i feel bad for them
for me you know like there was like 20
or 30 of them that
you know i was single from i was single
from
you know uh i don't know
91 to [ __ ] 95
what's single mean single means you're
getting [ __ ] right
it's just not none of it sticking around
they got other agendas too yeah
absolutely
so from 91 to 95 i was dating drug girls
girls would do drugs they did coke they
come over it too
can i come over with my girlfriend [ __ ]
no that's four noses
you know what i'm saying
that's four noses
[Laughter]
and it was kind of ugly like i looked
back at it like what a
like one like some of them i still
remember who they are and
i looked them up and they're married and
they got kids
the dirtiest one is like the president
of the pta right
oh i'm sure i'm sure because i still
talk to her parents i was tight with the
parents and stuff
and we used to do some dirty things on
sunday nights and now i sit here
me and her had a sunday night
relationship
she had a boyfriend she'd break up with
him every saturday right you should go
back to them on tuesday it was [ __ ]
disgusting that's
genius move by the way it's disgusting
it was such
disgusting so i look at those all those
relationships that didn't matter and i'm
like
what the [ __ ] you know yeah like how bad
was that like that's when i look at bad
stuff like i'm like
i feel so bad i wasted that time i don't
think you should
think of it as wasting their time
although there is a building whenever i
drive by it in west hollywood where i
shudder because i had a coke-fueled
night there once that was not correct
so still to this day even my kids were
little in the car i'd drive by like
it's about 1988 89
you know what i mean so but uh but it's
something i had to
go through and move on so i don't think
you should feel bad at all
you know i do it's weird like you do
you know i used to think like
how can i work with this girl again like
how can i hit so i
made a rule not to like sleep with
people that were close to you
that's a bad rule like people you have
to be around every day right that's
always bad
you know or get it out of the way okay
but it's just crazy that uh i still
think of all those
getting dismissed like that still hurts
it doesn't hurt you
it's just part of the game you know
you're going through
it's a you're going through broads
that's the way to put it
if sinatra was here that's what he'd say
to you
you're going through broads the same way
broads grow through men yeah
they go through they go through you know
it doesn't mean she's a [ __ ] or he's a
[ __ ] you just
meet 20 people that you right just don't
really
take it to the next level right and to
some people
sex isn't intimate you know what i mean
what do you mean like there's making
love and there's [ __ ] someone
to some people it's uh you know it's not
intimate
you could [ __ ] someone and for a long
time and there's
it might not be intimate you know what i
mean it's a lot about like this space
like
joey always makes fun of me for a girl
like milkshake there was a girl who i
was with after paula for three or four
months and well
i should have if i had met her at a
different time we might have like
dated and actually done stuff like
actually been a couple but
whenever i was right after a
relationship and i i couldn't the
thought of going out to eat dinner with
somebody
like i i was cringing i couldn't do it
and so we ended up breaking up because
she
she caught feelings after a while but
you know you i don't know
about what head space you're on too i
think well what i'm talking about no i
hear what you're saying but what i'm
talking about like i was engaged after i
got divorced
to this guy and he uh
was like a reformed king you know what i
mean like he had a
bag of uh goodies in his closet
you know and he'd be like uh you know i
really want to tie you up
like but sex was never there was never
eye contact in the most part of
pleasuring another person it was very
and
and he even asked me to marry him but
that was one of the decisions why
you know i didn't marry him because i
said to him one day because it started
to make me
uh feel like i had no value because the
thing is too if you're with someone
who's a kink
you have to escalate that [ __ ] you can't
just be like
i'm gonna tow your left foot up like
more than
one or two times and you gotta be like
well let me try an
arm too with that left foot you know you
have to escalate the
the thing about it you know and
uh that's so i do think uh
it's not always where you hurt a girl's
feelings
when you're wait because it's all it's
going the other way direction too
does that make sense yeah yeah you know
what one time in boulder
i went against my [ __ ] uh
my instinct i messed around with a
spanish
she was a hot little mexican chick that
her father owned the taco stand and we
used to eat at
and her and i used to like flirt like
and then one day her brother
threw me the number to the house and i
called the house and she answered
we started talking and her and i like
would've
i don't know i mean we dated
like uh she was really cute
but she came to my house
first three or four times and then one
night she goes
i live at my parents house part-time
but i have a roommate i have an
apartment with a roommate
when i go to school because she went to
school in colorado springs something
crazy so we had been together maybe two
or three times
it was pretty good it was drug field and
the whole thing
and then but every time before she would
come
she would always like say uh
i'm going to mount you tonight like it
was always like she
threatened me like i'm going to get on
top of you tonight like [ __ ] like that
then the third time she said something
to me and then we talked in between
it was like a week where she was busy
with school and i remember calling and
going so when am i going to see you
again
because my car wouldn't have made it to
[ __ ] denver in those days
i had a car that was a piece of [ __ ]
that the door had a
a bungee cord i had to collect the
bungee cord
if i was driving and i hit the bungee
cord i'd die the thing would just wrap
around my neck you know how many times
that thing almost took my hair oh my god
so i couldn't really drive a long
distance it was a car to drive
you know just around the neighborhood
and i said to her
uh she goes wait do you come to my place
and i'm gonna tie up
you're gonna love the whips and [ __ ]
never call her again
yeah yeah i know yeah like she was
talking about talking about my ass and
all this [ __ ] and whips and chains
you can just be like no thank you i said
i'll call you next week i'll call you in
a few hours
still waiting for the call she's still
waiting for the call
yeah she wanted to strap a dildo her
ex-boyfriend liked it
yeah you should try it i'm like i don't
think i'd really be into it
i'm telling you one time i'll [ __ ] you
love it
and she just so she wanted to spank you
okay
she wanted to [ __ ] me in the ass with a
[ __ ] strap on it right
and she was a beautiful girl i just
could not there was no way that was
happening
i don't personally like i did it because
i was like okay i mean i'm
just divorced why not right and then but
then after a while you're like
well he's just [ __ ] me up against
this mirror beating the [ __ ] out of me
you know what i mean like i'm
like if you know like and i'll let you
know and i'd be like can you like just
give me eye contact every third time
you know what i mean but i could never
understand the kink of it
that's because it's not my kink like he
would his thing is like he would want to
tie my left foot
to because he had a four poster bed the
giveaway right
so if a grown man has a four poster bed
get the [ __ ] out right
so he would like tied my leg up and the
whole time we were having sex i remember
this the first time we did it
i kept thinking like it was such a turn
on him and i kept thinking god
if he just would untie my leg i could
throw some more [ __ ] torque this way
you know what i
mean because i was just like it wasn't a
turn on to me
you know what i mean yeah once you take
it to a different
place like i have friends that have
cakes
right like i have one dear friend who
has tremendous kinks
and when he tells me about him i die of
laughter
like what is his weirdest king like a
mask with a zipper and
putting balls in your mouth and tying
you up that leather and all that [ __ ]
and
doing drugs i mean he goes all the way
and chicks go
all the way with him yeah and nobody's
ever accusing the rape
i know 20 women that have dated him and
they've all left on
great terms and i see the women that
he's dated in hollywood i just shake my
head
because i know at one time my boy adam
tied up with a ball in their mind
i see him on tv and i'm like my boy tied
that [ __ ] up to death
you know now my favorite ones are the
ones that like
go by rope at the hardware store and
they're like you wouldn't know
[ __ ] i had i had a horrible
problem i had a relationship with a girl
that i loved dearly i fell in love with
her the [ __ ] was that good
but her kink was getting beat up oh yeah
yeah i couldn't it was just terrible
but the [ __ ] that came out of her mouth
was you know
like it was just crazy like the choking
and all that yeah
once you start getting into choking you
lose me oh yeah that's when you lose
things if i got a choking for you to get
off
the craziest thing i did there was a
girl that i really
liked and for her to come you had to
come on her face
so you had to come on her face let it
drip
and then [ __ ] her and she could come
there
was a [ __ ] nightmare there was a
chicken boulder that only left me the
[ __ ] when she took sleeping pills
that's the only way she could come
uh-huh her wasn't xanax it was valium
stolen to
she took like 20 milligrams you don't
know how many times i ate a [ __ ] and
i'd be like
she's going to she'd be passed out
and she'd come and nod yeah she'd squirt
and that's how i would like to do this
i just get my [ __ ] and leave oh my god i
remember the first time i ever came
across someone that was a kink and it
was when i was 18 years old and i was a
stripper
at the peppermint lounge in colorado
springs colorado and there was this guy
that would come in he was probably like
40 i would guess right now
and he was a helicopter pilot for the
oil companies
right and he looked like a helicopter
pilot from the oil companies
very handsome right older guy right so
then we're like blah blah blah blah blah
blah
he comes over to my place and i eat
literally 18 and a half years old or
something like that he's like yeah
there's rubber bands in my pocket take a
rubber band out i'd be like why did i
just trust me
take a rubber band out
okay
he's like all right i just want you to
listen to me i want you to take that
rubber band
and i want you to put it around my balls
both balls tight
maybe do it twice three times a loop
okay
and i'd be like what what what i don't
know it's kind of weird you'd be like
okay i'm gonna show you the first time
they took
like right it looked like you know
trying to know if we reuse them or we
got new rubber bands every time
the craziest thing i do is i'm
uncircumcised i hold the tip and i'll
just sit there for like a minute
get my oxygen let the skin fill up with
all the sperm
and then i go to the toilet and it
actually sounds like they go bloop
it just comes out of my dick it hits the
toilet it looks like an oil spill for
like two minutes
it looks like the exxon bought these
right
i flushed that [ __ ] right here i
hear are you that man are you the man
a little spanish what does that mean
help me okay
that little spanish sperm right what
does it feel like just sitting there
holding your like the tips
i just sit there sometimes and think
about the whole situation how
embarrassed i am
i'm uh such and such year whatever
because i've been doing this since i was
like 20.
i finally realized what's the rush i'm
not going to come in my shorts
i'm not going to come in the bed and lay
on it but if i just take the four-stroke
together
it just fills up i just let it fill up
like a water balloon
that's not a bad idea to [ __ ] black
off on a balcony and see people walking
underneath
and let the balloon loose that's a
terrible one
well anyway let me finish it because i
started it so
so he has his two little smugglers right
and there and it's all
tight and then he goes he goes he goes
yeah
tap it and i go what he goes tap it
and i'm like when he eat and he goes
then he takes my hand and he's like tap
it right
and he's like it's just just my thing
just do it right so i would be like
and then he got so turned down i was
like yeah [ __ ]
and it was also very freeing oh
that is crazy i can't imagine
putting a rubber band around my nut sack
and hitting it like a belt
like just having like bang bang oh like
a boxing bag
like he wanted it like that isn't that
crazy
you don't like when people say you like
mushrooms who ate the first mushroom
who figured out that if you if you took
dog [ __ ]
cow [ __ ] and moved it over there'd be a
mushroom under it that's why
when i think about when i think about
after [ __ ] the guy from nxs who would
jerk off an entire thing around his neck
you know all those things have always
been very you know i'm a criminal
you want to talk about criminality stuff
i know about crime how to bury the body
but all that other [ __ ] i was never
really exposed to until
like two years before i moved here then
once you move here
you meet weird types of sex people yeah
i'm very lucky i met my wife when i met
my wife
because until the time i met my wife i
was meeting some weird [ __ ] women and
we were doing some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was not good and it was not healthy i
you know
when i go home and i'm thinking to
myself jesus christ
that just happened that's bad yeah like
just
just stupid sex with people yeah
unprotected you know
getting an 8-ball you know going to a
hotel it was terrible
well you said something the other day
about there's a lot of people where you
grew up that
married their high school sweetheart yes
and that's the other that's like the
opposite end of the spectrum like
that i have a friend who did and i
sometimes i'll think about like i wonder
if he
it has a good sex life like i wonder if
people like that are like fulfilled
if they if they really got someone they
wanted to spend the rest of their life
with
well i know someone that was uh high
school sweethearts and they have a very
active sex life
it's never slowed but they don't have
kids and they've been married
25 years but they never had kids
yeah crazy right i know it's such a
crazy concept like what
i like to have sex more but i'm
embarrassed to ask my wife like she's
tired after times it's like
why asking i'm sorry to go through the
whole [ __ ] thing
but when i was younger i would wear you
out if you were a woman
yeah like if you were my girlfriend i
wore you out
just not a principle [ __ ] it you're here
let's do it let's do it
why not right now you just come out of
the shower let's see what that monkey
smells like
it's fresh you know what i'm saying but
i'm gonna rush yeah who cares
everybody's already right
right well now hey now that i'm home
with my boys oh my god
it's not good you know it's kind of
crazy
felicia 10 years ago i was about to
11 years ago i was about to quit
comedy and i bumped into you and we
started a podcast and here we are today
i know a lot 2 000 [ __ ] nine
we did 100 episodes then i did 850 with
this mortadelle
and uh here here we are man you know
i mean we got into the podcasting thing
when there was
we were calling mark maron for advice
right
like the best the big guy in town was uh
corolla yeah that was the big guy around
town you know now look where the podcast
has gone to
so i wanted to get you three guys
together in the room
and say that we did the right thing at
the right time you know it's kind of
crazy
and even stopping doing beauty and the
beast was the right thing at the right
time for both of us yeah
at the beginning everything happens for
a reason oh for sure like i
i could see because i was the one uh
like when we had the little website and
people would write comments and it's
like
uh i totally could see that the
direction you needed to go
i just couldn't participate because i
had kids and a cranky ex-husband
you know what i mean so it's like i
couldn't you know and i totally get
why that change needed to be made you
know
but i enjoyed my time with you we had we
had a lot of fun yeah that movie was on
the other night i kept thinking you know
i was like
but it was too late i didn't want to
hurt your feelings
the guy that he said that that movie was
based off him the cop
who kept torturing you he he was friends
with your boyfriend and he did that cop
he did the movie colors it was one of
the last episodes yeah yeah
he did he was he was right cop that was
supposed to be yes
yes he was drinking yeah and he was
breaking your balls about
dave he kept asking you have you gotten
tested lately and you're like
he kept asking your [ __ ] different
[ __ ] i'll never forget that how much we
left
but the best thing from your podcast
that i learned was
storytelling oh for sure like this is
when
what people don't understand is what we
got into we were open microsoft podcast
for sure like we didn't even put up the
first episodes we did like
10 episodes where we just hung around
and just
talked and it was also like a learning
process in because you had come from
doing so much with rogan like uh no
jokes
no jokes felicia right because i would
come in with
you know and to learn i really truly
learned how to tell a better story by
hearing your stories
and and to it was such a process
of seeing uh you
uh elevate it every time you know what i
mean and
and sometimes it's better to start a
project without
a goal to just start a project
you know what i mean just figuring it
out not overthinking stuff
don't you agree all right listen when we
started the podcast
we knew nothing about nothing
we knew nothing about nothing just like
rogan
just like sam tripley just like bill
burr
you know mark marion was already on the
board with his
right tomorrow i mean we called mark
with vice couples right
right nobody really knew he was going
into the unknown not knowing
and now look at what podcasts have done
the last five years it's it's
you go on the list there's there's
millions of [ __ ] podcasts
and now there's no tv i wonder how many
tv produced podcasts are gonna come out
because
we're gonna go back to listening like
1955. uh-huh
you know we're gonna go back to let's
sit around the radio on saturday nights
and listen to
[ __ ] you know whatever but i just
wanted to thank you for uh
we did something really good uh i never
want you to forget that that
we did something really good and it was
like
it was the weirdest story because we had
been doing it for a while
and we were just going figuring out the
moves
and i told you a story about mother
hooker
and lighting her wig on fire and i
remember that
i was so focused into telling the story
you had spit things up uh-huh you had
mike
and i was so focused on telling the
story
about this hooker and how it you know
she got into a fight and then she
she tried to cut albie and then we got
her into north bergen and we took it to
the fairview cemetery
and then we drew out of the car and
she's like what you're going to kill me
you know and i remember at one point
looking at you because i was so involved
in the story
and your jaw was like [ __ ] wide open
and i go we're on to something
that's when i realized i was on to
something and it's like bert crisis said
because he told the machine story on
rogan
he's got to say it he's got to talk
about it now he just
he goes recently i stopped talking about
it because i stopped saying the [ __ ]
story i got sick of saying the story
right
right but that hooker story carried me
for a year
because people wanted to hear the hooker
story right
it's so [ __ ] weird how it all
came down from that yeah and i still
remember getting in the car like i had
done the longest yard
i had done a move with de niro i had
done taxi
i had done all these little things and
you know there's a thing called selling
tickets you know
and the improbable book you don't book
anybody if you're funny enough
you're right they'll book you and then
when you you know you sell
90 tickets they don't get mad at you
they'll rebook you but
they'll keep rebooking you to build your
career you know
and i'll tell you when i did the longest
yard at that time
the equation was you did a movie
you sold tickets you did a tv show you
sold tickets well
i did a movie and did the results sell
no [ __ ] tickets
so here i am banging my head off the
wall how do you sell a ticket
it it's really weird to think that
telling a story
about mugging a hooker and lighting her
wig
on fire changed my comedy career
for what it is today ray that is crazy
yeah
that is crazy it's just insane to me
yeah that telling that story changed
everything
and then i take like you look at my two
specials that dog [ __ ]
but if you look at the [ __ ] things i
did for ari
that's my best work that's
oh this is not happening yeah that was
my best work that's my i was so
loose because it was our army and i knew
that
i had to do good for arie yeah like it
was so different where my motivation was
but you learn all these things
but going back to the podcast can i just
say i hate when you
downplay their your specials like i i
joey when i watch your second special i
started to cry like i was overwhelmed by
it
like i i don't like when you do that
we all feel it's like you know sometimes
you
you eat somebody's [ __ ] but you didn't
need it right no but from the get-go you
were like ah
and i was like no that's a [ __ ]
sometimes sometimes you just feel weird
but
we did some special something very
special felicia someday
you're going to write a book you're
going to write a journal
somebody's going to write a book about
podcasting or something
and our names are going to come up in
that book so
yours certainly
yeah you were the uh
the bridge to the tunnel you know what i
love about
our story together is uh how
i had gotten divorced and i've said this
before
but uh and no one would talk to me in
comedy and i wanted to get back in and
you were the only one that
reached out the only one joey
what does that tell you about this town
for this show yeah
it tells me that people are [ __ ]
hungry
whether they really are hungry or
emotionally hungry or you know
you know right now we're living in a
time in comedy where
we're seeing our friends getting accused
of
things that we can't believe you know
whether it's rape or and we know these
people
we've been around them been around them
for years i mean the lucky thing about
you is not to
make you look whatever is that
you were around for the two big greatest
bangs of comedy
i know a lot of people can't say that
you
dice i know you know in that whole thing
you saw both of them were both drug and
fueled and sex related both
boost were were you know surrounded by
[ __ ] babies it was different like
when you were saying earlier in the
podcast about
how you how you sometimes miss
how rowdy comedy was or how unforgiving
it was like when you were
like being at the store and you know in
the middle of the 80s how crazy it was
like i
[ __ ] miss sometimes i get it i get it
it can't go on like that but i miss how
literally it was like
you know uh craziness it was just
insanity and for the store to have the
talent that they had at this
last ride there had to be a tamer there
yeah there was too much talent at that
store from jeremiah watkins
to jessica wellington to [ __ ] moses
you know i really really really want you
to think of the spectrum of the store
as far as talent is concerned never mind
the bill birds and the dave chappelle
and joe rogan
anwar think about the [ __ ] ones
think about the [ __ ] black kid the
nice kid that does the
the brian simpson brian moses oh brian
moses is a great guy
think about you know you you think about
the spectrum thing about the people that
were just coming up brian simpson
annie letterman he just had on like to
see
annie letterman man check the last year
has been phenomenal to see her [ __ ]
so you look at that spectrum
to control that thing you had to have
management there
when the mh ran the asylum there was
talent down there
but there was a lot of bad talent down
there yeah there was more bad talent
than what was good talent yeah and when
this
organization came in they told those
people
don't come around here no more because
mitzi
had created when i was the host there on
sunday nights
there were 60 guys from the kennison
days that were out there every night
and they were just looking about you
just making yourself look bad go home
go home your time came it went
right accept it do something else
and move on so hard it's hard but it
isn't hard right now i'm at the
crossroads of mine
right now and i'm 57 and i'm like one by
the time we get to do stand up again
where am i really gonna be
you know let me tell you something i
mean i'm not talking about you
you look beautiful i know that this
three-month pandemic has put
four years of wind damage on my face i
feel the same way i'm telling you right
now that i saw pictures of friends of
mine on facebook
i'm like we've aged that much in three
months
yeah once this slows down and the
pandemic goes away we'll
un-age but we're aging uh
triple at the amount right now because
of the way we're living yeah because
it's stressful we're living i'm
living healthy i'm drinking [ __ ]
water i'm doing all the right stuff
but our minds are getting
weird you know right i don't even know
where i was going well i just think
because it's so uncertain
right now it's so uncertain you know if
you are blessed where you don't have to
worry for your own safety or your own
needs
you it's you are completely
you know full of empathy for people that
are going through so much like
think about all the young comics or a
lot of people are moving out of town a
lot of people
you know are don't have means and and
it's
it's unsettling like what what's going
to happen two months from now
what's going to happen you know what as
a matter of fact when this podcast hits
we'll be out here
i know but i mean felicia you
joey just said you went through both
booms but you also
were went through being one of the
biggest comics in the country
to not to not doing it for a long time
right and working your way back to the
comedy store
so you like joey was like you were just
saying you don't know what's going to
happen
felicia's proof that you can not be on
stage and then get back on comedy is a
journey
yeah tommy might shift though comedy's
gonna shift
comedy might shift comedy might do a lot
of stuff
but uh i'm just happy we were part of
you being the beast
thank you i was part of the comedy sport
with you
and i was happy that you gave me advice
in 94
and look where we're at 26 years later
and we're still friends and i love you
all my heart happy chair
and i'm happy you can make it on for the
you're the last guest
of the church or what's happened now get
the [ __ ] out of here really yeah
we're just gonna do a wrap-up and we're
gonna leave him a gem
uh-huh next week we're gonna surprise
him and
uh that's it lee's gonna go to milwaukee
i'm going to new jersey and you're going
to new york
so we will all be gone real quick
before i get out of here i don't want to
forget nothing to nobody
remember the church podcast today is
brought to you
by stamps.com as we slowly adjust to a
new normal
we still need to do business as usual
how are you supposed to do what
what you're supposed to do while you're
keeping six feet away from other people
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier
thousands i'm talking thousands of small
business owners
have discovered the benefits of using
stamps.com
in the recent months they've been able
to keep their businesses going
while avoiding crowds at the post office
print postage at home
and skip the lines with stamps dot
com plus save money on discounts you
can't even get at the post office
and now stamps.com is working with ups
get discounts
up to 62 percent like i told you in the
beginning of the show
my wife does everything on stamps.com
when i go home now
there'll be boxes out waiting for the
[ __ ] mailman and we watch them like
hawkers we got ring people are stealing
your mail again around here
they're stealing they're going into
whole buildings with
masks on and gloves and taking all your
mail
at one shot to do insurance scams so
watch your mail
if you're in the la area because they've
got sticky fingers
speaking of stamps.coms they bring the
post office
into the comfort of your home skip the
line
print postage 24 7. any letter
any size package going anywhere in the
world
right from your couch and the best part
is the mailman will come and pick it up
just like i told you
no contact required it's that simple zip
zap you also get great discounts get
five cents off every first
class stamp and up to 62 percent off
shipping
save up to 62 on ups rates plus never
pay residential surge charges again
uncle joey's coming through for you guys
stamps.com is a no-brainer
especially now it saves you time money
and it keeps you safe you don't got to
walk around you're not going to die on
facetime
so right now right now stamps.com
is gonna give you a special offer for
the church family
a four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts
it's easy
go to stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the home page
and press in church that's stamps.com
preston church stay healthy [ __ ]
that's it and that's that the next
church podcast
will be leah and myself uh fair
welling you [ __ ] but for today
felicia michaels
is our last guest and i love you though
oh i [ __ ] love you guys
good luck i love you guys yep good luck
to you [ __ ]
and we'll see you monday morning tip top
magoo
take this [ __ ] mueller
[Music]
you
[Music]